(brouhaha)
(coup de sifflet)
(huées)
- (foule): Shame on you!
- On ne peut pas dire que
les candidats à la chefferie
des conservateurs étaient
tout à fait les bienvenues
à Perth, en Écosse.
- (foule): Shame on you!
Shame on you! Shame on you!
- Liz Truss, la grande favorite,
et Rishi Sunak sont venus
plaider pour l'appui
des membres de leur part
Mais à les entendre,
un néophyte serait pardonné
de croire qu'ils ont
tous les deux un adver
commun dans la course.
(applaudissements)
- Nicola Sturgeon n'est
pourtant pas candidate.
(applaudissements)
- Nicola Sturgeon n'esturururur.
Mais la première ministre
écossaise et cheffe du Parti
national écossais, le SNP,
pèse lourd dans la campagne
des conservateurs, ici.
Pour gagner la confiance
de leurs membres, résolument
en faveur de l'union, les deux
prétendants au poste de premier
ministre doivent démontrer à
leur base qu'ils sauront freiner
les ambitions séparatistes
de la dirigeante de l'Écosse.
À l'extérieur du théâtre,
une poignée retentissante
de manifesrarararappellent
aux candidats que l'indépendance
de l'Écosse reste, plus
que jamais peut-être,
d'actualité pour eux.
Forte d'une victoire décisive
aux dernières élections
au Parlement écossais,
Nicola Sturgeon entend bien
aller au bout de sa démarche
référendaire d'ici un an.
- Now is the t
for independence.
- Order! Order!
- L'ennui, c'est que
sa tenue doit être confirmée
par la C d d d des communes
à Londres. Un obstacle de
taille. Pour le contourner,
Nicola Sturgeon a sollicité
la Couêêêême britannique.
Elle demande un avis sur
la légalité d'un tel vote
sans l'accord du Parlement.
Ruaridh Hanna est le parfait
exemple de ce qui a changé.
En 2014, il a voté non et
a fait activement campagne pour
rester au sein du Royaume-Uni.
♪ ♪ ♪
62 % des Écossais
ont voté contre le Brexit,
ce qui exacerbe pour certains
un sentiment d'isolement et
d'impuissance face à Londres.
ELENA WHITHAM, députée,
Parti national écossais (SNP)
- On peut pas faire qu'est-ce
qu'on veut ici. On n'a pas
tous les pouvoirs.
Ici, en Écosse, nous sommes
à la gauche. Westminster,
c'est à la droite.
Puis, si on veut avoir
le pays à la gauche,
avec l'argent pour
tout le monde, avec
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire,
il faut avoir l'indépendance.
- Elena Whitham est députée
au Parlement écossais.
Celle qui a grandi et fait
ses études au Québec avant
de retrouver son Écosse natale
croit que si le référendum
sur l'indépendance de 2014
s'est soldé par un échec avec
55,3 % des électeurs contre,
les conditions actuelles rendent
une victoire à portée de main.
- La dernière fois,
on était à 25 %...
et on était rendu à 45 %.
Puis là, on a eu Brexit,
une pandémie, un premier
ministre qui... ment tous
les jours, on a une crise
du coût de la vie.
- Encore faudra-t-il
qu'un vote ait lieu.
Dans l'hypothèse probable
où la Cour suprême se prononce
contre la légalité d'un scrutin,
Nicola Sturgeon promet de faire
des prochaines élections
législatives britanniques
un référendum de facto sur
l'indépendance. Un pari qui
pourrait lui coûter ses appuis,
qui sont nationalistes,
certes, sans pour autant
êdédédédépendantistes.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Édimbourg